[Musique]
salut tout le monde euh
justin ici euh
je voulais vous mettre à jour les gars sur
ce qui se passe
euh évidemment comme vous pouvez probablement le voir
sur mon visage
euh
j'ai euh
ce syndrome appelé euh
euh le
syndrome de ramsey hunt
et c'est à partir de
ce
virus
que euh
[Musique]
attaque le nerf de mon oreille
comme vous pouvez le voir cet œil ne clignote pas
je ne peux pas sourire de ce côté de mon visage
cette narine ne bouge pas
donc il y a une paralysie complète sur le côté de
mon visage donc pour ceux qui sont frustrés
par mes annulations des prochains spectacles euh
je suis juste physiquement évidemment pas
capable de les faire je vous aime les gars
merci d'être patient avec moi
et euh je vais aller mieux et je
fais tous ces exercices faciaux pour
avoir mon visage  retour à la normale et euh
ça va revenir à la normale c'est juste le temps
et on ne sait pas combien de temps ça
va prendre